good morning john when we look out at
other solar systems in our galaxy the
thing that captivates us the most is the
potential of finding
other earth-like worlds rocky planets
inside the habitable zone of their star
not too close that the water would boil
away not so far away that all the water
would be ice but this is more a question
of whether we could live there
less a question of whether there could
be life there but if we're talking
conducive to life we've got some
problems first the places most conducive
to life outside of earth and our solar
system are
outside of the habitable zone they are
enceladus and europa two ice moons of
gas giants that both definitely have
giant oceans of liquid water beneath
their icy surfaces
the second problem is that we've
actually got two planets in our solar
system mars and venus that were probably
habitable
for a pretty long time one of them mars
is in the habitable zone the other venus
is not though admittedly now neither of
them are great candidates for human
habitability
mars as you may have noticed is not a
verdant ball of life and venus is even
worse you could probably live longer on
the surface of mars without a space suit
then you could live on the surface of
venus
with one highs on venus are like 900
degrees celsius that's enough to melt
lead so it makes a kind of sense that in
our search for life in our solar system
we focused on mars
not because it's the best candidate
though it's a fine candidate but because
it's just a lot easier to work with
but we have over the years noticed some
weird things about venus
areas of its thick clouds that get dark
for some reason that we can't explain
for example which has led to people
looking for
how life might exist there here's the
thing if you move away from venus's
surface and towards space
well they say it gets colder cold enough
that steam condenses
into droplets of water the temperatures
and pressures 40 to 60 kilometers above
the surface of venus
are like florida except for the part
where the water droplets are highly
concentrated sulfuric acid
venus sucks no life on earth could live
in water anything
like that acidic but life does sometimes
find a way the thought is that maybe
some kind of microscopic life could live
inside of these water droplets and then
as they eventually and inevitably fall
toward the surface of venus
those droplets evaporate and those cells
are then able to enter some kind of
dormant spore stage until they get
tossed back up into the nice part of the
atmosphere again and this is just
guessing but it means that maybe it's
worth looking looking to see if maybe
there are some chemicals in the
atmosphere of venus that we can't
explain and that's why it was a big deal
this week when among the rest of the
world being an unforgivable mess
scientists announced that they'd found a
seemingly impossibly high concentration
of phosphine in the atmosphere of venus
phosphine is nasty stuff if you're a
human but it's okay for some
microorganisms they produce it as a
waste product specifically bacteria
that don't use oxygen in their
metabolism and phosphine
can't exist in the atmosphere of venus
very long there are processes that would
break it down pretty immediately so it
existing
means something is creating it now of
course there could be some unknown
geochemical process that produces
phosphine on venus and if so
just figuring that out would be a big
deal and there's a phrase that often
comes up in the search for life on other
planets extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence and so if
you're going to claim that life exists
somewhere else in the solar system we
need the big proof which the authors of
this paper confirm would need to be an
actual visit to the upper atmosphere of
venus and i imagine that that mission
will happen in my lifetime which is
super exciting but
i actually don't think it's
extraordinary to claim that there is
life elsewhere in the universe maybe not
even in the solar system look we've
never found a way to duplicate the
cascade of chemistry
into life in the laboratory but it's
also definitely a thing
that happened and if a thing can happen
once it can happen
again it can probably happen again a lot
so if it happened to happen on one of
our next-door neighbors
that would be extremely exciting but
maybe
not as surprising as we might at first
think
john i'll see you on tuesday gosh it's
impossible to not tell you about scishow
space at the end of that video if you
like
this kind of stuff scishow space is the
channel where we talk about this
twice a week and it's great it's hosted
by me and caitlin and reid and it's
right here on youtube
where you can find it any old time okay
bye